4 on dispose aujourd'hui retrouvent pour
une petite compilation de jambes a joué
à trois jeux qui coûte 99 centimes
chacun où commence avec there is poupe
il my soul avec maturité supprime
permettent traduction il ya du caca dans
ma soupe alors apparemment il faut
lancer des cacas par exemple le corps
les gazettes femmes
allez c'est là on adore la maturité ceci
est totalement répugnant on peut aussi
se faire la soupe du monsieur bhl à
auber sur la nuque changement nous
amuser une seconde phase qui tombèrent
c'est tendance à faire une compilation
de jeux d'eau près c'est plutôt pas mal
la hâte en sommeil ou la fé nouvelle
coupe de cheveux
bonjour
[Musique]
et
agacé ouest
oh mon dieu oh certes corse collet a mis
à celle là non là tout le monde possède
son caca sur la tête c'est l'heure du
jeu suivant
on ne m'attend sur watson de rieurs
blanquette qu'est ce qu'il ya sous ta
couette
les mecs on a tous vécu ça qu'on vivait
chez nos parents et peut-être est encore
en train de le vivre d'ailleurs le
principe extrêmement simple il faut
finalement se frapper sous la couette
comme on fait tous chez nous de temps à
autre on va pas se mentir
sauf que là la maman qui arrive et on
s'est fait [ __ ] à temps mais c'est la
peur mais barron's a abusé à temps mais
je crois qu'en fait tu les entends
monter l'escalier attentes autant jeu
concentré je concentrés auxquels a eu du
bruit j'arrête
voilà papa la moustache tu vas te calmer
on se lève on ferme la porte et on
pouvait retourner soit padeg maman t'as
pas vu mon pénis depuis mai cinq ans et
c'est pas près de changer y est je suis
pas par le même temps ce genre doit pas
couler monte les marches très stressant
woaw mots je faisais rien sous cette
couette maman ou papa est en lumière
adore et qui fait ça en plein jour comme
ça le connard de chart's encore plus
stressant que sa mère était dans la
pièce d'avoir son [ __ ] de chaleur
dégage malgré yassa le bloc salle
blanqui dont il peut plus il peut plus
rien faire affalés que j'attrape [ __ ]
mais du coup je suis baiser attend la
même flacon ce fabuleux très vite
auparavant la [ __ ] rouge c'est trop dur
c'est trop dur ça brûle ça fait mal
c'est essaimant la mecque ont fait appel
aux pouvoirs du biceps s'arrime homme et
tout est dit je me permets tout la mer
elle flaire comme ça que son physique
touche quoi ça n'a aucun sens
oh c'était limite oh [ __ ] la
grand-mère au plus la bonne grommerch se
garde bien noël balata plus de cadeaux
c'est fini tu es revient vite tu es dans
le lit troubles et à la saq
quoi quoi douleur mais d'où la police
belge et moi avec
mais laissez-moi me fap est acquis c'est
déjà arrivé
non mais je veux bien qu'un menbre de ta
famille te prennent en flagrant délit
mais que les flics viennent parce que tu
as fait trembler le lit et toute la
ville en te fasses veut aussi un jeu
très technique de malades avec deux
doigts
comment c'était limite j'ai vu la
moustache de mon père se poser des
questions même si je sais que ça tu
manques mais ce taux plein ne vient pas
de danger quand je fais ça merci
ah merde à je peux pas me lever qu'on
est encore sa tête [ __ ] je m'énerve là
j'ai pas de moi je m'en bats les
couilles connard de chats je t'attrape
je te tais je t'emmènerai espère voir
iron rôde toujours [ __ ] les sous la
couette c'est glauque non mais metz va
bosser [ __ ] mais ya des chiens de
chats errants dans ce quartier à la
partition du pays gouro c'est quoi ça
c'est pour mépriser avant la level 2 du
fâ ping c'est ça oh [ __ ] on connait
tous ces policiers les mecs arrêtez
arrêtez
comment c'est long mais qui doit de lac
à les pompiers vient d'éteindre aux
mondiaux j'ai mis le feu à ma [ __ ] mais
non [ __ ] j'ai ma j'en peux plus c'est
moi qui vais plus pouvoir m'échapper
pendant des années là j'avais mal du
tout quand tu te fasses ça fout le feu
est ce qu'on allume un barbecue avec son
pénis
non est-ce qu'on allume sa cheminée avec
un pénis non plus à temps de ma petite
soeur a des doutes sur fait que je me
masturbe elle vient avec sa tête quoi
elle juste intéressé [ __ ] s'amuse et
ce à partir de l'inceste ok le val
d'oise partie ouais je suis sur dofus
qu'es-tu affaires saloperie de belle
mère va je t'ai jamais mais de manière
non pas non plus
elle a fumé pour j'arrête ouais je me
passionnais 92 way nouvelle 96 allez on
s'appelle belle-mère on s'appelle face à
face à abidjan alors c'est étrange mais
j'ai un malin plaisir à jouer le jeu
alors à m'expliquer pourquoi entre de
masturbation on affronte un mec au bras
de fer c'était bizarre je perds moins
que ça laver les mains ok c'est parti le
23 alors là on va être comme en automne
à rumes mec à la firme rim c'est quand
même mon père le moustachu qui vient
quoi mecs trop dur trop dur je
n'aimerais pas j'y arriverai pas j'y
arriverai pas mais je vous assure que là
c'est ultra dur mais regardez ça scott
1,99 tourner normalement [ __ ] je crois
qu'on va pas y arriver au père yves et
le pouvoir du pénis est trop fort pour
nous aller le pit stop ce type nous
échappent et en moi
la voie aux gars que j'ai fait ça toute
ma jeunesse sauf un bras de fer où un
rappel chinois sans se pose la question
à la salle de monsieur mais t'as pas
honte
ahmed ounaies msa au gaz en douce e mail
vient me surveiller la salle de muscu
quad et j'en ai marre je veux plus je
veux le jeu suivant puis on ramasse
mythos apéritif
on est maintenant sur shake i are you
tube monnaie simulateur 2016 ce coûteux
youtube monnaie donc on pourra juste
secoué notre nom mais c'est en quartz ou
que vous cliquez comme un bourrin mais
quoi j'en peux plus ah j'en peux plus
[ __ ] mais c'est le même jeu qu'avant
sur le thème de l'argent sauf que j'ai
des pistes elles s'épuisent et quoi un
vrai plaisir à ok en fait je lance des
tonnages sur une danseuse d'accord j'ai
pas vu mondiale est totalement un homme
en plus j'ai pas compris jusque où je
dois aller la shoah 210% tu vas soit
plus apparemment il reste douze secondes
en bas à gauche mme amara ce que ça
donne à la fin de seconde à une seconde
c'est fini game over meilleurs jeux 2016
jusqu'à pas de cette vidéo n'était pas
là mais ça vous a plu pas besoin de
s'attarder plus sur ce dernier jeu qui
est très bon nul à chier je crois que
watson d'orior blanquette a fait la
vidéo vraiment un plaisir absolu
la prochaine fois vous frappez fait
attention on n'est jamais à l'abri d'une
petite maman qui vient te prévenir que
le repas est prêt à la toute prochaine
vidéo portez vous bien le document bis
[Musique]
oh